[Musica]
[Applauso]
perché in una calda giornata d'estate il
nostro cono gelato si scioglie
beh perché il calore tende a fluire
dall'ambiente esterno che è caldo al
nostro core generato che freddo e lo
scioglie
questo è il secondo principio della
termodinamica vedete la fisica vuole
descrivere i fenomeni che noi e speriamo
tutti i giorni ma non solo vi ricordate
gravity è il film con george clooney e
sandra bullock nel momento in cui il mal
capitano malcapitato cabina capitano
kowalski si stacca dalla navicella
spaziale perché si rompe il cavo beh in
quel momento lui è destinato a
disperdersi nello spazio interplanetario
e questo perché perché in assenza di
forza e quindi anche di attriti come
nello spazio un corpo quando in uno
stato di moto permane in quello stato di
moto rettilineo di forme indefinitamente
ed è questo quello che condanna il
capitano kowalski assicura morte e non è
altro che il primo principio della
dinamica le leggi della fisica e la
fisica in generale creano dei modelli e
modelli servono per descrivere quello
che accade ma la bellezza di questa cosa
che ogni tanto i modelli hanno carattere
predittivo ovverosia riescono a
prevedere dei fenomeni che non abbiamo
ancora osservato questo signore qui e
franco pacini era una
dico italiano che ha diretto
l'osservatorio astronomico di arcetri
vicino firenze per oltre 20 anni fino al
2001 e lui ci fornisce un grandioso
esempio della capacità predittiva della
fisica ed è un esempio che a me
particolarmente caro perché è molto
vicino a ciò di cui io mi occupo tutti i
giorni franco pacini prevede l'esistenza
delle pulsar cosa sono le pulsar
avete presente quei fari sulle coste che
durante la notte con le loro luci
pulsanti fungono da riferimento per le
navi beh immaginate dei fari nel cosmo
adesso cerchiamo di immaginarci la
materia più densa che possa esistere
all'universo ed ora mettiamo insieme i
fari nel cosmo e la materia prudenza
dell'universo ecco queste sono le pulsar
sono degli oggetti straordinari un
cucchiaino del materiale di cui è fatto
una pulsar pesa centinaia di miliardi di
chili ma sono oggetti abbastanza piccoli
se noi potessimo appoggiare una sulla
superficie terrestre non occuperebbe più
della superficie della città di roma
eppure peserebbe una volta e mezzo il
peso del sole la terra quanto tempo ci
mette a ruotare intorno al proprio asse
un giorno
questi oggetti ruotano attorno al
proprio asse svariate centinaia di volte
al secondo
beh pace ne prevede l'esistenza di
questi oggetti e le loro caratteristiche
fondamentali con un articolo che
pubblicava nel 1967 il fato volle che
alcuni mesi dopo la pubblicazione di
questo articolo
due astronomi britannici jocelyn bell e
antoni flash per caso durante le loro
osservazioni astronomiche identificarono
quegli oggetti questa che vedete è una
pulsar molto famosa la pulsar è il punto
lino luminoso in centro a questa
immagine è la poule 7 granchio che si
trova al centro di questa bellissima
nebulosa la nebulosa del granchio e paci
ne prevede inesistenza di questa pulsar
prima di qualsiasi osservazione diretta
ma ritorniamo alla fisica
allora secondo al fisica moderna
esistono quattro forze fondamentali in
natura aria acqua terra e fuoco nessuno
dice niente
vi siete tutti addormentati sono
noiosissima no non sono suoi quattro
forze fondamentali in natura le quattro
forze fondamentali in natura sono la
forza di gravità
la forza elettromagnetica e due forze di
tipo nucleare e io adesso mi voglio
concentrare sulla forza di gravità la
forza di gravità della forza attrattiva
tra le masse e la forza che ci tiene
attaccati al suolo e la forza che fa
cadere le mail e dagli alberi ma è anche
la forza che da girare la luna intorno
alla terra e la terra intorno al sole ed
infatti è stata proprio questa geniale
intuizione di newton a spiegarci che in
realtà questi due fenomeni
apparentemente così diversi
lamela che
dall'albero il moto planetario sono
tutti e due dovuti alla stessa causa
la forza di gravità ma la teoria moderna
della gravità non è la gravità di newton
è la teoria della relatività generale di
albert einstein e cos'ha di particolare
la teoria della relatività generale
beh immaginiamo uno spazio tempo che
abbia delle curvature le masse creano
nel loro intorno
degli avvallamenti una curvatura in cui
le altre masse tendono a cadere quindi
le forze attrattive tra le masse vengono
descritte dalla teoria della relatività
generale come una curvatura dello spazio
tempo la terza della relatività generale
è una teoria incredibilmente elegante ma
delle applicazioni pratiche che di voi
nelle ultime 24 ore ha usato una delle
applicazioni che si trovano oggi giorno
su tutti i nostri telefoni cellulari che
vi ha permesso di raggiungere una
destinazione un particolare indirizzo
per questi sistemi di navigazione non
potrebbero funzionare ha fatto ve lo
garantisco
senza la teoria della relatività
generale
una delle conseguenze fondamentali di
questa teoria sono le onde
gravitazionali e per fondamentale
intendo dire che se la teoria giusta
alle onde gravitazionali debbono
esistere e che cosa sono
sono delle increspature dello spazio
tempo che viaggiano alla velocità della
luce e sono prodotte ogni qualvolta
delle masse si muovono in questo momento
sto mettendo un de gravitazionale
infatti a dire il vero tutti noi adesso
siamo immersi in un mare di onde
gravitazionali ma sono così deboli
impercettibili che assolutamente
impossibile rilevarla a questo livello
per rilevare
onde gravitazionali ci servono dei
segnali molto piu forti
ci servono dei segnali che sono emessi
da masse che si muovono molto
velocemente
ma se molto compatte e comunque molto
pesanti per esempio due buchi neri che
negli ultimi istanti della loro vita
spira luciano l'uno attorno all'altro
sempre più velocemente in un ultimo
valzer fino a fondersi in un unico buco
nero
il segnale di onde gravitazionali che
questo fenomeno è messo viaggia
attraverso il cosmo per miliardi di anni
indisturbato codificate all'interno
della forma d'onda le informazioni su
quest ultimo valzer che le ha generate
questo importante perché buchi neri non
emettono luce e quindi le onde
gravitazionali sono gli unici messaggeri
di quello che accade loro qual è
l'effetto
delle onde gravitazionali come si fanno
rilevare le onde gravitazionali
stiracchiano e comprimono gli oggetti
che attraversano un po come queste onde
gravitazionali che stanno arrivando
sulla terra ma vi dovete preoccupare qui
l'effetto è amplificato in modo
assolutamente irreale semplicemente per
illustrarlo su un antenna gravitazionale
che qui fotografata e che ha due bracci
ognuno dei quali è lungo 4 chilometri
gli stiracchia menti delle compressioni
indotte delle onde gravitazionali
ammontano a un milionesimo di
milionesimo di milionesimo sono arrivata
di metri ovvero sia una variazione di
lunghezza che è più piccola delle
dimensioni di un atomo
c'è voluto un team di più di mille
scienziati che hanno lavorato per
decenni per riuscire a rilevare questo
segnale
il 14 settembre del 2015 finalmente
arriva un segnale chiaro
seguono dei mesi di lavoro molto intenso
per verificare la correttezza di questa
misura per documentare tutto e per
scrivere un articolo scientifico che
farà storia e me la ricordo bene nella
conferenza stampa
sei mesi più tardi a washington queste
foto che vediamo sono presi da
quell'evento in cui venne dato
l'annuncio fu una emozione
indescrivibile tutto il mondo per un
paio di giorni ha celebrato con noi
il successo di questa avventura
dell'intelletto umano
un'avventura che era cominciata cento
anni prima con albert einstein che aveva
proposto la teoria della relatività
generale e teorizzato per la prima volta
l'esistenza delle onde gravitazionali
era continuata con il lavoro degli
astrofisici teorici che avevano previsto
i particolari segnali emessi
da certi fenomeni astrofisici e poi con
gli ingegneri e fisici che avevano
dedicato la loro vita a cercare di
rilevare il loro effimero lievissimo
passaggio fino ad identificarne
l'origine e avevano vinto questa
scommessa un anno e mezzo più tardi
accompagnavamo i padri di questa
scoperta a ritirare il premio nobel a
stoccolma
questi sono barre bearish kit for e ray
wise che rappresentano le tre anime di
questo esperimento il glorioso apparato
sperimentale l'astrofisica relativistica
e la sinergia della big science che è
necessario per metterlo tutto insieme
farlo funzionare
a questo punto generalmente mi viene
detto tutto ciò è molto bello ma qual è
l'utilità pratica di questa scoperta e
qui voglio essere assolutamente chiara
per il momento questi segnali sono
complicati abbastanza da misurare che
delle applicazioni pratiche per noi con
le onde gravitazionali ancora non
esistono ma io sono sicura che come
tutte le pietre miliari del progresso
scientifico
anche questa le onde gravitazionali
entreranno magari fra cent'anni nella
nostra quotidianità
così come adesso lo sono i navigatori
sui nostri cellulari
per ora quello che posso dirvi però è
che questa ricerca che è durata 20 anni
ha già avuto delle importanti ricadute
tecnologiche per esempio quando siamo su
un aereo
quanto è importante sapere che esistono
delle tecnologie laser che premettono di
verificare l'integrità strutturale dei
composti di carbonio di cui ha fatto
l'aereo beh questa
una delle ricadute della ricerca
gravitazionale la teoria madre dello
spazio tempo se lascio correre la
fantasia non potrà che avere delle
applicazioni fantascientifiche ma per
ora le onde gravitazionali ci permettono
di indagare una delle forze fondamentali
in natura la gravità e come messaggeri
dei fenomeni che le hanno generate
aprono una nuova è una nuova era quella
della astronomia gravitazionale che io
sono sicura sarà ricca di rivoluzionarie
scoperte quindi vanno ad arricchire il
patrimonio culturale dell'umanità e come
tale la loro valenza prescinde dall
immediata e contingente applicazione
pratica per me sono un po come la
cappella sistina al rinascimento
italiano
vi chiederete mai qual è l'utilità
pratica della cappella sistina
ecco per me è lo stesso per le onde
gravitazionali
[Applauso]